arrêtez de nous compter comme des
moutons après leur clip très remarqué
pour dénoncer le projet de fermeture
d'une classe les parents d'élèves de
l'école de Chançay récidive en quelque
sorte ce week-end ils ont fait venir 3
moutons 3 comme le nombre d'élèves
requis par la direction académique pour
maintenir cette classe une action
symbolique que nous raconte Aurélie
Renaud avec Romain Delville
il manque théoriquement trois élèves
pour maintenir quatre classes dans leur
école à la rentrée casse la tienne les
élèves de Chançay ont accompagné ce
week-end des moutons dans la cour 6 au
vin parmi lesquels sont renommés Bernard
Lucie Ginette ou encore Lucien des
camarades à quatre pattes pour atteindre
le nombre d'élèves requis par
l'Inspection Académique alors si vous
tournons dans l'école de chantier cet
après-midi parce que on nous a dit qu'il
manquait 6 élèves pour maintenir une
classe donc et bien on a trouvé les six
élèves derrière cette démarche
humoristique il y a une incompréhension
et une inquiétude pour les parents
d'élèves avec le départ d'une professeur
les élèves se retrouveraient tous dans
des classes à triple niveau dont deux
classes avec plus de 25 élèves et la
situation dégradée selon eux ne
pourraient pas être pérenne puisqu'une
douzaine d'arrivés sont programmées pour
la rentrée d'après il y aura pas assez
de tableaux dans le genre où il y aura
il y aura trop de travail pour les
maîtresses moi mon fils a des
difficultés beaucoup de difficultés il a
besoin d'une aesh et donc je me je ne
pense pas que le Tripoli nouveau soit
adapté pour un enfant difficulté on va
privilégier des
instituteurs pour donner des cours de
français et de mathématiques à des
collégiens et on préfère supprimer des
classes à un niveau de primaire auquel
l'enseignement de ces matières là est
nécessaire depuis que la fermeture d'une
classe a été annoncée dans la presse les
parents d'élèves réclament qu'on arrête
de compter les élèves comme des moutons
en intégrant de vrais moutons dans les
effectifs ils prennent le contre-pied du
comptage qu'il dénonce tous espérant en
tout cas que les autorités
décisionnaires sauront entendre leur
revendications